hey guys how's it going hi dom hello how
are you
i'm good thanks for joining the fun here
yes we had planned on doing
another video well we are doing one on
your channel also
it's about the note 9 and i was like
well i don't have one yet and you guys
will not believe
this came in the mail today so i said
change everything
we're doing an unboxing here it is which
one did you get i also have the same one
that you have
is it's the lavender or lilac is that
what i think it's purple
were they calling it lilac before or i
think they weren't okay
you're not crazy i thought they were
yeah this is i mean this color is
amazing
they're pretty similar i think this
one's a little lighter oh it is actually
maybe just slightly
this is like a little more purple yeah
so that makes sense this is a little
more lilac
i like to call this thanos purple oh yes
so good so you've had it for how long a
couple of weeks now
are you loving it i like it a lot yeah
it's pretty cool i'm so excited that
you're here
to do this unboxing with me this is
exciting okay so here we are oh you also
have the galaxy watch too
this guy yes oh this is so awesome
this is yeah this is interesting i'm i'm
actually excited to look at this
so let's see i know i have a knife here
somewhere
knife status that's a knife i'm trying
to find a purple one which is weird i
don't have a purple knife do i even need
this
i remember it was really hard to get
mine out of the little sleeve that it's
in
cut away from yourself i know don't cut
towards yourself
this is a substantial box yes so this is
the 512 version
did you get an sd card for yours have
not yet i feel like you don't really
i mean it's 128 like i have a 256 iphone
and i haven't even used half of it yet
no
my sister the other day she was like my
phone's going it's slow
i think my my phone's full we looked at
the storage and i was like
you have a 256 iphone yeah you've got
like 200 gigs left
and here it is
[Laughter]
yes i mean it would be better if they
had it flipped over right true
of the color i mean i would be more
excited but i already saw yours and i've
seen
every single person's videos and
unboxings so this is really not that new
information but for me it is
this is my first touch yes it is your
first impressions
yes here it is i do love the color the
color is nice
have you seen anything so beautiful i
have yes you have
it's just as beautiful it is really
really nice
it is kind of crazy the the colors
though it's like yeah it is slightly
different
just just a little bit yeah that's more
of a pink and that's more of a purple
what else do we have in here do we have
a pair of headphones
i'm not sure we definitely got a charger
and a little dongle
adapter whatever you want to call it
yeah charging
wall oh geez have you guys seen these
akg headphones i actually like them a
lot yeah i know they're cool they're
pretty yeah they came with the s9 oh
well nice little
have you guys ever seen one of these
this is called usbc
it's fantastic very new technology
that's a little that's a clip to remove
the
tips from the s pen and it comes with
extra ones too i did not know what this
was
when i first did a note unboxing extra
little
ear thingies and that's it that's
it okay well now that we've got that
taken care of
yes there it is i mean that's the
unboxing i will be doing a further test
doing some photo stuff
later on the camera is nice i'm excited
so what's been your favorite feature
do you think if i'm gonna be super basic
about it
that feature where you can take a selfie
with the pen is pretty awesome
that is kind of cool snap it and it
takes a picture like
it's really cool it seems so easy i'm
sure there's like a lot of intricate
things did your phone just talk to you
more easily by guiding you through the
steps
i'm not ready yet we're chatting about
things so what have you mostly been
like doing are you doodling are you like
taking notes because i don't really
think those are things that i
realistically would ever really do so
for me
when i get like a note at first it's
always exciting right away and then the
novelty wears off
after like a couple of months and i'm
like i'm not using this so right now i'm
using the heck out of the little
selfie shutter that is cool but i don't
know you know it could be in a few
months and i'm like and just
you know take a regular selfie it's cool
that you can just take like pdfs from
your email and just sign them
because that is probably a struggle that
i think a lot of people do deal with
trying to to sign things i mean i have
like a pdf of my signature that i just
like copy and paste onto things
but what about the camera so it has the
variable aperture the same as the s9
plus which is really cool
i like that a lot i mean if you like the
s9 camera then you know
it's the same thing basically they kind
of copied it over which isn't bad like
i mean you have to the variable aperture
is nice
i like the super slow-mo a lot like was
on the s9
yeah so that's pretty cool too um the
camera overall
i mean it's pretty good it is a really
good camera it's up there for sure
the live focus versus the portrait mode
in different situations and different
hair colors so for blonde hair
the portrait mode on the iphone it does
not like it but it works way better on
my sister
whereas this one it works pretty well
with both hair colors i would say this
is definitely like
top five for me yeah as far as cameras
go and even all around smartphones i
mean i know the year is not finished and
there's other stuff that's going to come
out
but right now i mean they've got it
going on with that they do and this
color is great
yes oh it's so good we do have this
should we jump into this real quick
we might as well okay jump into this
i'll let you do the honestly
i won't cut anything i don't think you
have to cut it i don't think there's
actually any tape
this one's much easier to get into than
the other box was so usually i never
have to cut anything but i cut
everything
oh yeah this is way easier yeah whoa
see that's cool they actually give you
the the product right up front
that looks really good do you want to
take it out okay okay there you go it
actually looks pretty cool
it does it's a little thick big it's a
little thick
so for the first few years of the apple
watch i didn't realize that
i should not have a large version when i
finally switched to the 38 i was like
this is the perfect watch like i didn't
even realize how
massive it was the 42 is pretty big it's
huge and i had no idea i just thought i
needed to see the screen
i don't even like you don't no that's
unnecessary so
i think these come in a few different
colors too this is a silver one
obviously but then they do have a black
one
and a rose gold version as well yeah
they have rose gold i know
what it looks pretty nice though i i
will say my one of my favorite things
about
the samsung watches as of the last like
year or two i guess
is that you can navigate using the thing
you can go through the menus and stuff
i'm using that but this one actually
looks like you know like a real watch i
guess
aside from the screen you see that
that's something that doesn't turn on
galaxy watch there's something happening
it's light it's not
it doesn't feel very heavy either it's
big it is i mean it's 46
and one yeah wow okay that's that's even
bigger than like the biggest apple watch
yeah i mean i guess it just depends on
the size of your wrist that i mean it
fits you
yeah i do like what they like i don't
know it just looks it looks
normal and i from what i've saw on the
internet it actually makes like little
ticking noises like an actual watch does
oh that's cool
apparently i'm into that yeah let's see
yeah so you can like
i mean i have to set this up and stuff
but you can move up and down and stuff
with that little rotating bezel which is
kind of cool that's cool i love
sort of the normalization of smart
watches like michael kors has them i did
a video about that and i was like this
looks like i love michael kors watches
but since the apple watch this is
basically all i've been wearing
but with that it also works with apple
because using just like the android wear
yeah you don't you can still use your
iphone too were there any
health benefits was there like it does
like all tracks all the things
you know like if you're sleeping or like
your rem cycles and stuff like that
it obviously has a little heart rate
sensor on the back there that can
check your heart rate throughout the day
actually when they sent it to me it came
in like a nike like gym duffel bag oh
that's
they're kind of pushing the whole health
aspect of this thing a lot
they realize like the trend of like
fitbits and like fitness bands are kind
of going down so they're trying to step
up and like take that spot with like
watches like this yeah the only way that
i think that those sort of bands will
come back is if they start tracking
things that these cannot
like oxygen levels like dehydration
those types of things like blood sugar
like those are the only
way that i feel like those are going to
take over these smart watches especially
if every brand and
is basically coming out with them a
smart thing i would love
if there was a fitness band that was
specific to fitness that would help you
hack all those things yeah that would be
cool yeah but
there's not the feeling that i'm aware
of actually yeah yeah i keep seeing all
these crazy fitness things coming out
i'm like we're gonna
like put this they've got like fitness
mirrors yeah like crazy things just sort
of extend out of it to work out
technology is crazy it's amazing i just
want to be a robot yes move well someday
we will yes we'll take our brains out
and put it into like the cloud
yeah yes it'll take us to the cloud i'm
down and i'm ready
well thank you so much for joining me
thank you so much for bringing this i'm
excited to try out the new phone
and make sure you go check out his
channel because we're going to be doing
another video
on yours and it may have something to do
with that
so we'll see okay i'll see you later and
uh
let's cut to some photo tests
hey welcome back to santa monica we're
here with the phone
now that i've unboxed it as you guys
just saw we're gonna do some photo tests
i'm just gonna run through a few things
one of the highlight features for me for
this phone is you can store up to a
terabyte of data which is kind of
incredible i got the 512 model
but you can upgrade it to another 512
which will give you so much space that
i'm not really sure if you're gonna even
know what to do with it
you can probably see jenna in my glasses
there say hi jen
we also got our super 73 bikes so we're
gonna be riding around town
getting some photos and some video tests
i'm excited to try out the slow-mo
the super slow-mo should we try that out
yeah do you want a super slow-mo me on
the bike oh yeah
okay cool let's get started
[Music]
so here is the front-facing video i hope
that the wind isn't too loud
but so far i'm really really into the
video if you guys liked the samsung s9
video camera this is basically i think
it's very very similar if not exactly
the same
there's jenna now let's switch to the
back camera and
let's see uh see jenna here in a second
there she is everybody there's jenna
hello what's going on
so i'm gonna zoom in and see what this
looks like 2x
zoom she looks great
[Music]
one of the things that i like about this
camera is to identify what it's taking a
picture of so when i was at lunch it
noticed that i was taking a picture of
food
so it kind of auto-generated settings
that would look best for taking photos
of food
shall we cruise on maybe we head home
and
take some photos in the backyard because
it's too hard to do things out and about
especially on a bike
because people keep wanting to stop and
talk about the bike
and then they see we have a big camera
then they're like what are you filming
and then a lot of things
happen i just i don't think i should
ever leave my house again
let's go home
[Music]
so we made it back home i should just
shoot all my videos out of here because
it's perfect lighting no people are
bothering me and i'm in a very
uncomfortable position
i spilled i'm a hot mess maddie who's a
good boy
so you can turn the background focus
off or on
who dropped their bone good shot and you
can go back
in and you can adjust the background
focus afterwards
i will say sometimes these photos look
way better on this
samsung phone and then you share them
out and they don't look as good because
the screen on this thing looks so
incredible
so here's another one you can also do
the close-up
or you can switch back to the other
camera because there are two cameras on
here
so this will give you the wide angle or
this will give you the close-up
with the background focus blur look at
this dog i'm gonna post it on his
instagram
i think he will wait are you digging
let's see what else we can do
the super stoma looks really good
oh buddy you're so cute maddie so you
guys remember the ar emoji these things
i'm sorry they're extremely creepy
there's no doubt about it if anybody
disagrees you're crazy because let's
make one of myself
ready so smile my lips close and give it
a whirl
sorry wow okay
here it goes
[Music]
oh my god i'm gonna do that i'm a crop
top
oh wow
okay i'm gonna save it i don't love it i
don't love it either
okay so this is my ar emoji
uh wow i mean i definitely
think that i might not be okay with
what's happening
look i can share my feet
no tongue detection wowie
this is a look like half of my mouth is
working my eyes aren't working properly
are my are my eyes blinking right now
okay well that's good i've got a lot of
eyeliner on i don't ever want to see
that again
okay so here oh look at that that's a
breakfast pick
that looks pretty oh that looks
these photos are very very detailed that
looks very nice
there you are you don't
but that's okay here's the super slo-mo
bacon
these look really good oh look at you i
think that's cute
[Music]
oh i'm reliving this meal it was
delicious
yeah this looks pretty good i feel like
the coloring does not
like the skin tones on here do not look
very good
another cool thing that i like is you
can make gifs from videos which it's so
easy to do all you have to do
so find the video that you like you
swipe over here on the little panels you
click animation
you pick the section that you want to
make into a gif
click record and then stop guess what
you've got yourself a gif
and you can save it share it do whatever
you want that's not really a new feature
you could do that in the s9 as well but
i think it's pretty fun so here it is
there's my diff let's see me rolling
it's a good one i like it it's a good
one i made that like two seconds
i'm so talented it's shocking
well guys thank you so much for watching
make sure you go subscribe to dom's
channel and go tell him that i said
hello a huge thank you to him for
coming over and doing this unboxing with
me i will uh probably be posting some
more photos on
instagram and twitter oh i forgot eve i
forgot to try out the selfie
the remote's pretty cool um anyway i
forgot what i was saying uh subscribe to
dom subscribe to my channel click like
on the video
hit the bell i don't know i'll see you
guys my next video bye
let me know what you think of the note 9
i'm into it i don't know where i'm going
actually i was just saying
it's got to go this way i was just
trying to exit the video and he called
me out you're like where are you i don't
know
okay bye i'm i gotta go out at this
video now
you